hola de nuevo bueno cambio te prometí
que te daría unos problemas más sobre el
teorema de pitágoras así que lo voy a
hacer voy a darte más problemas sobre el
teorema de pitágoras y borro esto
primero así que bueno una vez más esto
esto es simple práctica digamos que yo
tengo un triángulo tengo un triángulo
así
y digamos que es un tipo de triángulo es
un triángulo rectángulo aunque este me
quedó un poco feo así que adiós a este
dibujo otro nuevo
este es un triángulo rectángulo que
también me queda un poco feo pero
digamos que este lado mide 7 digamos que
este otro lado mide 6 y queremos
averiguar cuánto mide este lado así que
hagamos eso ahora en el vídeo pasado
cuál de estos lados es la hipotenusa es
lo que vimos hay que identificar la
hipotenusa es el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 90 grados así que en realidad
queremos saber cuánto mide la hipotenusa
cierto así que bueno queremos queremos
saber cuánto mide la hipotenusa 6 al
cuadrado más 7 al cuadrado es igual a la
hipotenusa al cuadrado así que es igual
a al cuadrado eso es la hipotenusa al
cuadrado y bueno 36 6 por 6 36 más 49
eso es 85 entonces 85 es igual así al
cuadrado 85 es igual a sea al cuadrado
o lo pongo acá porque ya no tengo
espacio entonces se es igual a raíz
cuadrada de 85 ahora puedo yo factorizar
el 85 para que sea producto de un
cuadrado perfecto otro número
veamos 85 es divisible entre 4 creo que
no entonces no será divisible entre 16 o
cualquier múltiplo de 4 entonces ok 585
cuántas veces cabe siempre tampoco ahí
se puede entonces creo que ya han dicho
ya no es actualizable así que puedes
pueden puedes corregirme pero creo que
no creo que me haya equivocado aquí lo
puedes hacer después así que bueno aun
creo que ya tenemos la respuesta que
queríamos es raíz de 85 y si queremos
estimar más o menos lo que eso es bueno
hay que pensar en la raíz de 81 es 9
y la raíz de 100 es 10 así que será algo
entre 9 y 10 tal vez sea algo más
cercano más cercano al 9
acaba de ser algo así como 9 punto algo
algo algo y tiene mucho sentido porque
tenemos aquí 6 tenemos acá 7 ya que
serán 9 punto algo algo algo algo tiene
mucho sentido y bueno hagamos otro
ejemplo así que voy a dibujar otro
triángulo rectángulo
aquí está su ángulo recto y digamos que
este lado mide 10 entonces 10 este 3
queremos saber cuánto mide este otro
lado primero hay que ver cuál es la
hipotenusa es el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 90 grados entonces esta es la
hipotenusa y es el lado más largo luego
tenemos que 10 al cuadrado es igual a la
suma de los cuadrados de los otros dos
lados entonces eso es 3 al cuadrado y
llamemos a este lado a entonces más al
cuadrado eso es igual a es igual a 100
igual a 9 más al cuadrado y ahora sigo
de este otro
agua caliente en espacio entonces al
cuadrado es igual a 100 menos 9 y
entonces 100 menos 9 así que al cuadrado
es igual a 91 a es igual a raíz cuadrada
de 91 y bueno creo que tampoco se puede
simplificar esto porque 91 es un número
primo no estoy muy segura pero pero
bueno genial ya ya terminamos de hecho
aquí también entonces déjate por otro
problema y en este voy a incluir otro
paso otro pasito sólo para confundirte
porque creo te lo estoy poniendo muy
sencillo entonces sigamos con otro
ejemplo así que digamos que tenemos
bueno tengo aquí otro triángulo otro pez
y todo estos de triángulos entonces otro
triángulo y una vez más te recuerdo que
estamos solo con triángulos rectángulos
de hecho nunca nunca intenté es usar el
teorema de pitágoras si no tienes un
triángulo rectángulo puede ser muy
peligroso debe ser muy debes estar muy
seguro asegurar que que es un triángulo
rectángulo en este caso tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo con este lado que
mide 5 y si yo te digo bueno mira mira
a este ángulo mide 45 podemos entonces
saber la longitud de los otros dos lados
bueno en si aún no podemos usar el
teorema de pitágoras correctamente
porque el teorema de pitágoras que nos
dice dice que si conocemos dos lados
podemos entonces conocer el tercer lado
aquí tenemos un triángulo rectángulo y
sólo sólo conocemos uno de los lados así
que aún no podemos averiguar la longitud
de los otros dos lados pero pero pero
sería muy bueno usar esta información
estos 45 grados para saber cuánto mide
el otro lado así que y así ya podremos
usar el teorema de pitágoras bueno
sabemos que los ángulos de un triángulo
suman 180 los ángulos internos de un
triángulo suman 180 siempre espero se
pase eso y si no lo sabes es mi culpa
por no enseñárselo desde antes lo siento
mucho y bueno hay que averiguar cuánto
miden los ángulos de este triángulo
cuánto suman los ángulos internos de
este triángulo pero usando esta
información podemos averiguar cuánto
miden entonces bueno ya sabemos qué
tenemos 45 más este llamémosle x
entonces eso es una equis nos entiende
pero es una equis así que bueno 45 más
90 más éste mide 90 más x será igual a
180 cierto sí entonces
ok bueno porque los ángulos internos de
un triángulo suman 180 y bueno aquí
sería 45 + 90 135 35 este es un 5 más x
es igual a 180 luego restamos 135 de
ambos lados x es igual a 45 entonces x
es igual a 45 grados interesante no
crees me parece muy interesante x
también mide 45 y tenemos un triángulo
con ángulos de 92 de 45 ahora te voy a
dar un teorema que también te va a ser
muy útil y creo que bueno en este
teorema no tiene nombre no tiene un
nombre especial de alguien o lo que sea
pero es un teorema bueno lo que dice es
que si yo tengo un triángulo voy a
dibujar aquí otro triángulo entonces
bueno
voy a dibujar este triángulo donde dos
de los ángulos base y cuando yo me
refiero cuando yo te digo ángulo base me
refiero a dos ángulos estos dos ángulos
miden lo mismo
llamémosle
y los lados que no comparten estos dos
ángulos comparten este lado cierto pero
si observamos los lados que no comparten
sabemos que esos dos lados miden lo
mismo son iguales así que bueno se me
olvidó en este momento cómo se le llama
a esto en geometría pero si tiene nombre
este teorema no lo recuerdo ahora y de
hecho tiene mucho sentido esto no
requiere es tanto que yo te lo diga pero
bueno como yo puedo dibujar un ángulo
así si yo cambio uno de estos ángulos
también va a cambiar a longitud otra
manera de pensar en esto la única manera
bueno
de hecho no no te quiero confundir pero
puedes ver que si estos dos lados miden
lo mismo entonces estos dos ángulos van
a medir lo mismo si yo cambio la
longitud de uno de los lados eso hace
que también la longitud de los ángulos
cambien no van a medir lo mismo pero
bueno hay que dejarlo así por el momento
no vamos a entrar esto a más detalles o
no sólo toma lo que te digo que sí que
si dos ángulos de un triángulo son
equivalentes entonces los lados que no
comparten también miden lo mismo
entonces bueno son los lados que no
comparten este
y este lado van a medir lo mismo y aquí
tenemos un ejemplo donde tenemos dos
ángulos iguales ambos miden 45 grados
eso quiere decir que los lados que no
comparten este es el lado que comparten
este lado es el que comparten entonces
esos dos lados los que no comparten son
iguales este lado y este otro lado miden
lo mismo tal vez en este momento tú
digas esto se esté experimentando un
momento de baja o genial no espero eso
así que este lado es lo mismo que este
lado si sabemos que este la 2005 también
este lado mide 5 y bueno aquí ya podemos
usar el bien conocido y famoso teorema
de pitágoras
esta es la hipotenusa también de hecho
no olvidemos mencionar eso sí decimos 5
al cuadrado más 5 al cuadrado es igual a
digamos pse al cuadrado donde se es la
longitud de la hipotenusa y bueno esto
es igual a 50 es igual a c al cuadrado y
obtenemos entonces se es igual a raíz
cuadrada de 50 52 por 25 entonces es
igual
a raíz de dos igualdad ahí lo tienes
perfecto interesante todo este asunto
ahora ya tienes ahí mucha información es
pero no te haya confundido si lo hice
vuelve a ver el vídeo pero el próximo
vídeo te voy a dar más información aún
aún más sobre este tipo de triángulos es
un triángulo muy común es un triángulo
que se llama triángulo 45 45 90 tiene
mucho sentido eso porque es la medida de
los ángulos internos que tiene de hecho
también te voy a enseñar una manera de
una manera rápida de usar esta
información si tú tienes un triángulo de
este tipo 45 45 90 podemos saber cuánto
miden los otros dos lados si tienes la
medida de uno de los lados entonces
bueno espero que no te haya confundido
nos vemos pronto bye